the hong kong real estate tycoon thomas  kwok was today sentenced to five years  in jail bringing to an end a spectacular  seven months trial which has fascinated  hong kong society  the combined wealth of the entrepreneur  and his family is estimated at around 14  billion euros  the case is a win for hong kong's  anti-corruption task force also jailed  is the city's former deputy leader  rafael hui who will spend seven and a  half years in prison on graft charges  according to the ngo transparency  international hong kong ranks 17th out  of 175 countries in terms of corruption  whereas mainland china comes in way down  at number 100  beijing is also waging war on corruption  even against top officials  yesterday chinese authorities announced  an investigation of an adviser to former  president hujin tao  earlier in the month the top security  adviser was arrested and expelled from  the communist party for suspected  corruption  you